[Music]
monica crowley she has a powerful new
op-ed out today in the hill entitled
federal abuses on obama's watch
represent a growing blight on his legacy
now Monica writes quote in all the
discussions about the political
weaponization of the Department of
Justice and the FBI alleged corruption
at the highest echelon of those agencies
in serial abuse of the secret FISA
process surrounding the 2016 election
one name has been conspicuously absent
President Barack Obama here now with
reaction senior fellow at the London
Center for Policy Research Monica
Crowley judicial watches president Tom
Fenton and Florida Attorney General Pam
Bondi Mike let's let's start with us
because yeah it's all true isn't it that
she rigged a primary she Pam can answer
this later but I've never heard of an
exoneration months before interviewing
the main people in an investigation that
allows her to continue she pays for
Russian government Russian propaganda
that gets used for a FISA warrant they
don't tell the FISA judge she bought and
paid for it and that it's not verified
that's all in order to disrupt a 2016
election how does this get to Obama
I think the Susan Rice memo the Grassley
grant memo might be giving us some
insight yeah you know Shaun we've been
talking about the to sort of surface
things going on here and the purpose of
the weaponization of the DOJ and the FBI
in the Obama administration one was to
protect Hillary Clinton from prosecution
and make sure she was in fact the
candidate because she was joined at the
hip to Obama
remember the Benghazi attack remember
the the knowing and repeated
communications over her server and by
her private email account so they had to
protect her in order to protect
President Obama if she were guilty of
committed committing felonies then so
was he so they had to insulate her and
the other part of it is of course they
hated Donald Trump's that they wanted to
derail him but nobody is asking the
bigger question as to why and that's
what I tried to get across in this
column today at the hill Sean which is
that Barack Obama essentially fulfilled
the long-held leftist
of changing the nation on a leftward
trajectory what Obama himself called the
fundamental transformation of the nation
there was no way right and there was no
way that he and his team and the Clinton
squad also was going to allow those
eight Obama years of leftist
achievements be reversed by none other
than Donald Trump Pam the zeroed out the
evidence of the email server I've listed
them enough times on this program that
multiple felonies were committed but
then you have the FBI director and
there's Trump hating higher up
individual Peter struck and as mistress
and then Andrew McCabe is there talking
about insurance policies so this the fix
is in right you're a prosecutor if you
ever exonerated or begin an exoneration
letter months before you interview the
key people in the investigation it never
made sense and then that all leads to
her stay in the race paying for the
Russian lies and then you go to a FISA
Court and you withhold information isn't
that lying by omission to a court Sean
it's more than lying by omission when
they go for a FISA warrant they have to
swear under oath that the facts they're
presenting the judge are true and I
can't believe that the judge hasn't
pulled them back already into court to
undo what's happened it's ridiculous and
Anna FISA warrant that's one of the most
important things we do as prosecutors
because you are invading someone's
privacy
you are wiretapping their phones you are
listening to everything they do that's
why that information has to be pure and
clean the Grassley grab memo says that
the dossier was the bulk of information
evidence and so they hand this over now
three months later you got James Comey
right saying it's a trumpets not
verified in salacious mm-hmm but it's
only a footnote as we understand it to
the FISA Court
it may have political origins they knew
Hillary bought it they know she paid for
it they knew it was even probably not
verified but they didn't tell the judge
yeah what should have what should happen
now well the judge needs to bring them
back before that him they should all be
held in can
very minimum for bringing false
information to a judge
that's more than lying by omission they
did not give the judge all the facts
that I believe it was very falsified
what they did it needs to go back before
the judge and it needs to be wiped out
and everything you guys hearsay fruit of
the poisonous tree it's a very basic law
school principal but everything that
came out of that warrant is the fruit of
a poisonous tree I mean what that mean
general Flynn's guilty plea absolutely
everything should be everything and I
really cannot believe it hasn't been
brought back before the judge now that
you've revealed and Fox and everyone has
revealed all of them was there tom
Fitton I did see the president tweeting
you this weekend congratulations but
more importantly you're digging deep to
get will we ever get a look at how bad
this this FISA memo was or the arguments
made before the court is that something
maybe in redacted form we could look at
to see what they purposely did not tell
this judge that they knew at the time
well we sued for them there are these
dueling memos the Democrats are going to
have their memo eventually come out and
why is it we're relying on this summary
document let's get the underlying
information I know Nunez is asking for
it we've sued in court for it and I've
told the White House that they should
take this approach of extreme
transparency on this Russia gate it does
nothing to protect the president from
the solicit activity against him and it
protects people like Barack Obama and
the Justice Department in FBI that was
misused to target President Trump do you
know that the dossier is central to the
Russia collusion theory it's collapsing
and it was central to Russia collusion
theory we have reports today quickly
Shawn Barack Obama was given the dossier
he was given the dossier what did he
know and why hasn't he been questioned
about it
well that's a good point in that and the
Grassley gram letter to rice today
Monica Crowley they want to know what
was talked about on January 5th and what
Susan Rice had note to self on just the
hours before they leave the White House
doesn't that seem a little odd that
letter that she's sending out
well yeah but I mean look the ideas
shown that any of these people in the
executive branch under President Obama
the branch he oversaw that any of these
people call me Lynch McCabe the list
goes on struck page or that any of these
people freelanced any of this without
the atleast the tacit approval of the
president and/or his White House really
strains credulity here let me ask the
Pam you you read this letter Susan
Rice's email she's sending to herself in
the in the waning hours of the Obama
administration how do you interpret it
my interpretation is cya of course it is
that's of course that's what it is and
to say that the President of the United
States Barack Obama didn't know what was
going on is ludicrous and that's why
Monica's
brilliant op-ed made so much sense the
fundamental transformation of the nation
that's what President then-candidate
Obama wanted to do to our country now
it's cya by all of them he wanted
Hillary elected so he could not only
protect his liberal agenda but also to
protect himself from everything that the
country was right now on the last day is
gonna cover up all of this that's a good
shot but I don't think it's going to
happen alright good to see you all